the 1980s had wild fashion classic music
and angsty teens the one thing it was
missing a handsome Victorian era corpse
who comes to life and has to find fresh
body parts via casual murder of small
town residents oh and he has the help of
an angsty teen who's in love with him
sound confusing it won't be once you've
watched Lisa Frankenstein I thought I'd
take a look behind the scenes of this
upcoming zombie romantic comedy okay so
let's start by piecing together what we
know about the basic setup of of the
movie and in a minute you're going to
enjoy that I use the phrase piecing
together trust me it all centers around
a girl named Lisa played by Katherine
Newton who is a bit of a kooky gal to
say the least she's an outcast at her
high school and her General taste in
guys probably doesn't help I say that
because she has a major crush on wait
for it a dead Victorian era statue in a
graveyard yep she Pines for and tends to
the bust of some long since dead guy in
a local Cemetery but it looks like she
does it in a quirky fun kind of way
she's the character we have to root for
after all so because it's a zombie
romcom I bet you see where this is going
in the trailer we see a lightning bolt
strike and then suddenly there's a
zombie attacking Lisa at her home in the
next shot but it's no ordinary zombie
people it's the dude from the graveyard
her Victorian era Crush of course there
are immediate problems not the least of
which is that he's missing some
essential Body Parts Plus he's you know
rotting so the two of them decide to fix
those problems by well killing local
baddies and sewing their body parts onto
him see what I meant about piecing
together we're having fun all this
escalates into a murder spree as they
fall in love and he helps her find her
true identity Etc it's a lot to go
through just for a high school boyfriend
but a girl's got to do what a girl's got
to do as I mentioned Katherine Newton
plays Lisa and she's joined by
riverdale's own Cole Sprouse as the uh
Victorian zombie and from the looks of
it he had to get to set early every day
for a ton of makeup but it's worth it
cuz the character looks authentic and
hilarious veteran actress Carla guino
rounds out the main Trio as Lisa's
tormenting mom The Supporting Cast
includes Liza soberano Joe Crest and
Henry ikenberry Liza actually posted
some picks from on set which looked like
a total blast she was also interviewed
by an entertainment show from the
Philippines and she revealed that the
movie was it's just so much fun to do
it's like nothing I've ever done before
for it's so playful now I mentioned that
the movie takes place in the 1980s and
from the looks of the trailer they have
the 8S Vibe dialed up to a 10 which is
awesome the saturated colors the
Wardrobe the music and everything are
prime 1980s retro this was no
coincidence according to the director
Zelda Williams in an interview with
Empire magazine she talked about how
writer Diablo Cody integrated the 80s
nness of the world right into the script
she said quote I remember remember
Diablo put in the script how many
seashells were in Lisa's house and for
Zelda this was just a tip of where she
wanted to take the look of the movie in
that same interview she said quote a lot
of movies Don't Go full kitch they tend
to hold back and be based on our reality
of the 8S I was like no the things that
people have one of I want 10 of them
according to Zelda she fell down a
rabbit hole buying seashells and fiber
optic lamps from the 8S and then
continued from there even co-star car
Gino talked about not only how much she
enjoyed doing this out there movie it's
totally Bonkers crazy and that was such
so much fun but also how much the 8S
Vibe was dialed in this movie just sits
in such a sweet spot of the'80s if you
actually lived in the'80s you'll
recognize so many things and homages
which are really fun a music everything
now Diablo Cody isn't a newbie when it
comes to quirky kitch Juno or murder
Jennifer's Body but her inspiration for
this movie actually came from somewhere
a little different she's a big fan of
the classic flick Weird Science in which
a couple of dudes piece together the
quote unquote perfect woman using well
science in an interview Cody said quote
it was funny to me how the whole
Frankenstein narrative was co-opted in
the80s by movies like Weird Science
where they were like what if we could
create the perfect woman she added that
other than the Rocky Horror Picture Show
no one was making the building a Man
movie so she decided to make one she
added quote I thought what if a teenage
girl had the ultimate sensitive guy who
can't talk what would that look like and
how would we animate him then once I
thought of a faulty tanning bed we were
Off to the Races she's joined on the
project by firsttime director Zelda
Williams of course as Robin Williams's
daughter she's certainly seen her share
of movie sets but this is her first
chance to make a name for herself as a
director and from the looks of the
trailer she knocked it out of the park
in 2022 when the project was getting
underway she tweeted quote I know
Hollywood gets a bad rep for
regurgitating sequels and remakes and
reboots over and over and over and yeah
it totally does that but it's also
finally letting me make the most Bonkers
wonderful zombie script I've ever read
and for that I will be forever grateful
well I don't know about you but if
there's one zombie romcom set in the 8S
and featuring a Riverdale cast member
that I see this year it's going to be
Lisa Frankenstein okay maybe that's a
little too specific TBH it looks
hilarious kitchy and fun count me it
have any thoughts about this upcoming
flick pop them in the comment section
below